Of course, with less memory, you're going to run out
of memory more frequently. And you'll have to make sure
that your code is bulletproof in low memory conditions. But,
this also means that the garbage collector is going to
run more frequently. And, running the garbage collector will actually,
often, also cause a spike in battery usage. So, all
of these are true. However, the battery drain, caused by
the garbage collector, is less of a concern than stuttering and
other rendering problems that the garbage
collector can cause. When the garbage collector
needs to clean up, it pauses all
JavaScript execution and rendering on your thread.